[Musique]
aurore a soufflé sur une partie de la
france dont les yvelines la première
tempête automnale est passé dans le
département dans la nuit du mercredi 20
au jeudi 21 octobre des rafales de vent
enregistrées jusqu'à 120 km heure
résultat de nombreux foyers privés
d'électricité ou encore des arbres
déracinés le procès de la sextape de
mathieu valbuena s'est ouvert ce
mercredi au tribunal correctionnel de
versailles sur le banc des accusés cinq
personnes dont le footballeur karim
benzema représenté par ses avocats
un procès retransmis par l' agence
plaisir oise css prod lundi a débuté la
semaine nationale est là à l'origine de
l'événement l'association européenne
contre les leucodystrophies
un groupe de maladies génétiques
héréditaires qui s'attaque au système
nerveux au programme une dictée et
l'opération mets tes baskets dans le but
de récolter des dons
jean castex s'est rendu à saint germain
en laye ce jeudi 21 octobre au programme
du déplacement la visite du quai des
possibles tiers-lieux saint germanois et
des échanges avec les bénéficiaires une
structure qui accompagne les personnes
éloignées de l'emploi et puis de la
vidéoprotection mutualisés pour les
communes et intercommunalités pourrait
voir le jour dans les yvelines un projet
du syndicat mixte interdépartemental
seine et yvelines numériques présenté ce
jeudi à la ferme du manet
objectif mettre en place des centres de
supervision sur le territoire
[Musique]
pas